in this part of gaza known as
42 people were killed half of them
belonged to one family
the alcoholic lost 22 people across
three generations in their home
at the beginning we heard a strong sound
and our home violently shook
after that we gathered in the center
away from the windows and furniture
the second strike was stronger and the
walls began cracking
soon after the third strike we found our
home falling
we lived on the third floor and suddenly
we were on the ground
aside from anger and death shrapnel and
rubble
are all that's left in this neighborhood
the head of the red cross is here to see
the destruction for himself
many civilians women men and children
paid the ultimate cost the magnitude of
this destruction here
is is of course shocking and
heartbreaking
and it's an indicator of the number of
years that will be needed to build again
those private homes here and in many
other places in the
gaza strip 254 people died in the
offensive
the ceasefire between hamas and israel
has held for two weeks
but the reality for gazans is very much
the same as before the conflict
there is a lack of water electricity and
basic infrastructure
the only commercial border with israel
used to supply
goods aid and fuel is now closed
well the humanitarian situation in gaza
was already challenging before this
recent cycle of escalation of course
this 11th day of intense fighting is
adding
another layer of challenges in the many
fields
that are of interest to the icrcb the
supply
of drinking water the evacuation of
sewage but also all the support
hospitals health centers
the palestine red crescent society
for the alcoholic family they will try
to rebuild
like they have many times before
israel attacked without any notice or
responsibility they don't care about
human rights or safety of civilians
or even prior notice they didn't call us
like they did for other buildings
we were asleep and suddenly our home
fell over us
the price of a new home is out of budget
for now
but it's nothing like the price they've
already paid
um al jazeera gaza